This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Pete Bethune is a conservationist, and while that job title doesn't sound exciting, he's basically G.I. Joe, but for nature. He's stopped whalers and in the Pacific Ocean, he rescued a dolphin, held captive in an Indonesian resort. Oh yeah, and he's been stabbed twice.
这里是《99%不可见》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。皮特·贝休恩是一位环保主义者，虽然这个头衔听起来可能不太惊艳，但他基本上就是现实版的特种部队，只不过他是为了大自然而战。他曾阻止过捕鲸船，还在太平洋上救过一只被囚禁在印度尼西亚度假村的海豚。哦对了，他还被刺伤过两次。
That's the host of Science Versus, Wendy Zookerman, who I'm pretty sure has only been stabbed once. And recently, Pete's work brought him to Costa Rica, and that's where his luck almost ran out. This was just before Christmas. Pete was deep in the rainforest with his team, and they were looking for evidence of illegal logging and hunting. Picture it.
那是《科学对决》的主持人温迪·祖克曼，我挺确信她只被刺伤过一次。最近，皮特的环保工作把他带到了哥斯达黎加，而正是在那里，他的好运气差点用光了。这事发生在圣诞节前不久。皮特和他的团队深入热带雨林，寻找非法伐木和狩猎的证据。想象一下那个画面。
It's a lush forest, thick canopy, very hilly. But it's up and down, up and down, up and down. Really steep. It's got the most ferocious ants on earth, it's got poisonous spiders. They are all over the place and a lot of the trees have very spiky trunks on them, so you need to be really careful walking. That's pee. And while he was walking very carefully through the rainforest, something got him. I just felt this bang in the back of my leg and my first thought was someone that hit me. Like it felt like someone had a big sticker, a piece of wood in it, wet the back of my calf.
那是一片郁郁葱葱的森林，树冠茂密，山峦起伏。但地势极其陡峭，上上下下、上上下下。坡度非常陡。那里有地球上最凶猛的蚂蚁，还有毒蜘蛛。它们到处都是，而且许多树木的树干上长满了尖刺，所以走路时必须格外小心。说话的是皮特。就在他小心翼翼地穿过热带雨林时，有什么东西袭击了他。我只觉得右腿后侧挨了一下，我的第一反应是有人打了。感觉就像有人拿了一根大刺或一块木头，狠狠地戳了我小腿后面。
Then I looked down and then how I see this snake sort of recoiling away from me with its sort of head and it was sticking about two feet off the ground. And as soon as I saw it like like I knew it was a food lunch. The Fertilance or spearhead is the most deadly snake in Central America. Right away, Pete's colleague grabbed his cell phone. He had one bar of reception
然后我低头一看，接着就看到一条蛇正把头缩回去，它的头大约离地两英尺高。我一看到它，心里就凉透了，知道这下完蛋了。矛头蝮是中美洲最致命的蛇。皮特的同事立刻抓起手机。他只有一格信号
and called up emergency services. They didn't make it clear. You need to get their guide or hospital as quickly as possible or he is gonna die. Pete had maybe six hours to get to a hospital. And to get their guide or hospital as quickly as possible or he is going to die. Pete had maybe six hours to get to a hospital. And to get there, he had to dodge all the spikes and spiders and other snakes in the rainforest. Pete had two options. He could go up on the ridge of the mountain, which would use up his six hours. All he could go down through
然后拨打了紧急救援电话。他们说得非常清楚。你必须尽快把向导或患者送到医院，否则他会死的。皮特大概只有六个小时的时间赶到医院。而为了尽快赶到向导那里或医院，否则他就会死。皮特大约只有六个小时赶往医院。为了到达那里，他必须躲避雨林中的所有尖刺、蜘蛛和其他蛇类。皮特有两个选择。他可以沿着山脊走，这会耗尽他仅有的六个小时。或者他可以穿过
muddy creeks. That would be harder but also faster and he might get to the hospital in time. I remember looking at my map on my phone and thinking, you know, the only option here is we need to go down one of these creek beds. So I'm crawling on my ass, crawling down these little waterfalls, escartments, banks.
泥泞的小溪。那样会更艰难，但速度也更快，说不定能及时赶到医院。我记得看着手机上的地图心想，你知道的，唯一的选择就是沿着这些河床往下走。所以我只能连滚带爬地往下挪，爬过这些小瀑布、陡坎和河岸。
But as we're going down, I'm getting weaker and weaker, and the strobing now has moved all the way up to my groin area and eventually gets a stage where I just want to sleep, but I did think I'm not going to make this. My number was up. After trudging his way through waterfalls in mud, Peter arrived at the edge of the rainforest and onto a beach where he saw the coast guard. They lay me down on the ground and I'm just closing my eyes and you know, just hang on a little bit more, hang on a little bit more. He'd arrived at the hospital around three and a half hours after he was bitten.
但在我们往下走的过程中，我感觉越来越虚弱，那种麻痹感现在已经一路蔓延到了我的腹股沟区域，最后发展到我只想睡觉的地步，但我确实觉得我挺不过去了。我的大限已到。在泥泞的瀑布中艰难跋涉后，皮特终于来到了雨林边缘的一片海滩上，在那里他看到了海岸警卫队。他们把我放倒在地上，我只能闭上眼睛，心想，再坚持一会儿，再坚持一会儿。他在被咬大约三个半小时后抵达了医院。
His heart was racing and he passed out. When he came to, he started documenting everything that was going on. Good morning. Good afternoon, the patient we are in the world. So if you guys are uptight or not, what's happened over the last couple of days? By the time he got to the hospital, the snake venom had begun to destroy his muscles
他的心跳加速，随后昏迷了过去。等他醒来时，他开始记录发生的一切。早上好。下午好，我是世界上哪里的病人。所以不管你们紧不紧张，过去几天里到底发生了什么？等他到达医院时，蛇毒已经开始摧毁他的肌肉
and blood vessels. Pete's leg had ballooned to double its size. And something else had happened. A warning. We're about to talk about genitals. My b****** and b****** go all big and black. It is not an uncommon thing that happens with snake bite victims. That doesn't mean it's not quite a shock.
和血管。皮特的腿肿胀到了平时两倍大。还有一件事发生了。警告。我们接下来要谈论生殖器。我的睾丸和阴囊变得又大又黑。这在蛇咬伤受害者身上并不是不常见的事情。但这并不意味着它不让人震惊。
Oh, I remember I asked her on the news. It's like, is this normal bug? And she can moment you just say. Yeah, kind of, maybe. To turn things around, the doctors had injected Pete with snake antivenom. It raced through his body, fighting back against the toxins. And quickly, it was clear that it had worked. Pete was going to be okay, and by day 11, he was up and about. Feeling a lot better today?
哦，我记得我在新闻上问过她。就像是，这正常吗？她当时就说。对，挺正常的，也许吧。为了扭转局势，医生给皮特注射了抗蛇毒血清。它在皮立体内迅速奔腾，与毒素抗衡。很快，结果就很明显了，起作用了。皮特会没事的，到了第11天，他就能下床走动了。今天感觉好多了吗？
So I've started walking around for the first time I've walked. And if you didn't get anti-bannum, what would have happened? Oh, if I didn't get anti-bannum, I would have died. No question. So yeah, I was pretty lucky, eh? Well, that is a dramatic story, Wendy. But why are you telling us about it? So I really want to zoom into the part of the story where he gets that treatment, that
所以这是我第一次开始四处走动。如果你没有注射抗蛇毒血清，会发生什么？哦，如果我没有注射抗蛇毒血清，我绝对死定了。毫无疑问。所以，是的，我挺幸运的，对吧？好吧，这真是一个戏剧性的故事，温迪。但你为什么要给我们讲这个呢？所以，我真的很想把镜头聚焦在故事中他接受治疗的那个部分，那个
stuff that saved his life. That's the anti-vendom. That neutralizes the toxins. Exactly. The anti-vendom. So Pete got it and he survived. But many people around the world, they aren't so lucky. Some 100,000 people die every year from snake bites.
救了他命的东西。那就是抗蛇毒血清。它能中和毒素。没错。抗蛇毒血清。所以皮特注射了血清并活了下来。但世界上许多人并没有这么幸运。每年大约有十万人死于蛇咬伤。
100,000. And you can bet that to sharks, they kill maybe about six people globally every year. And so part of the reason that people are dying from snake bites is because they're not getting antivenom fast enough. And this is for a bunch of reasons, but the one that I want to zoom in on is the way that we make anti-venom. Because the system we have now is this complicated time-consuming inefficient process that in many ways hasn't changed for more than a hundred years.
十万。你可以打赌，鲨鱼在全球范围内每年大概只咬死六个人左右。人们死于蛇咬伤的部分原因，是因为他们没有以足够快的速度获得抗蛇毒血清。造成这种情况的原因有很多，但我想重点关注的是我们制造抗蛇毒血清的方式。因为我们现在使用的系统是一个复杂、耗时且低效的过程，在很多方面，它已经有一百多年没有变过了。
Okay, so then why is it so hard to make anti-venom? It all boils down to the thing that we're battling against. It's the stuff that we're trying to save ourselves from, the venom. It turns out that snake venom is truly nefarious. And I spoke to Christina Zedeneck, who studies snake venom at the University of Queensland in Australia about this.
好吧，那么为什么制造抗蛇毒血清这么难呢？归根结底，是因为我们在与之对抗的东西。也就是我们竭力想要摆脱的东西——毒液。事实证明，蛇毒极其邪恶。为此，我采访了在澳大利亚昆士兰大学研究蛇毒的克里斯蒂娜·泽德内克。
And she kind of told me all the horrible ways that snake venom can kill you. It's like you're almost getting digested alive. So there's that. That sounds bad enough. Yeah. Where does it at the beginning? So snake venom can have up to 200 different toxins inside it.
她向我讲述了蛇毒致死的各种可怕方式。感觉你几乎就像是在被活活消化。就是这样。听起来已经够糟糕的了。是的。这一切是怎么开始的呢？蛇毒内部最多可以包含多达200种不同的毒素。
And each of those toxins have sort of slightly different tasks. So some start attacking your muscles, others attack your nerves, and sometimes two different toxins can work together to really mess this up. You've got one toxin that's pretty bad on its own, and another one that's pretty bad on its own, but when you put them together and they like tag team against you. Whoa. Yeah. It's like suck eggs.
其中每种毒素都有略微不同的分工。有些开始攻击你的肌肉，另一些攻击你的神经，有时两种不同的毒素会协同作用，把你的身体彻底搞砸。你有一种单独来看就很糟糕的毒素，还有另一种单独来看也很糟糕的毒素，但当你把它们放在一起时，它们就像组队来对付你一样。哇。是的。就像双打一样。
The suck eggs, indeed. I mean, look, that's from a scientist. So we'll wait to say. OK, so this is what she's talking about. This is how the snake better be saying suck eggs. You could have one toxin that is going through your body and making it difficult for your blood to clot. And then at the same time, another toxin
确实就像双打。我是说，看吧，这话可是出自科学家之口。所以我们拭目以待。好吧，这就是她所说的。这就是蛇毒联手“双打”的方式。你体内可能同时有一种毒素在游走，让你的血液很难凝固。然后与此同时，另一种毒素
that is kind of making you bleed out, like it's punching holes in your blood vessels. You've got a hole caused by the toxins that's now open and you're spewing out red blood cells and plasma and platelets. But all of a sudden, you can't stop the bleeding in that area. Christina says that sometimes people can bleed from all over their body. Yeah, yeah.
会让你流血不止，就像在你的血管上凿洞一样。毒素造成了一个现在处于开放状态的洞，你的红细胞、血浆和血小板正在喷涌而出。但突然之间，你无法止住那个部位的出血。克里斯蒂娜说，有时人们会全身流血。对，对。
So like your gums from your eyes, sometimes your ears or your sphincter, your butthole. Oh, geez. And even if it's really bad, there was a tie-pan by Nostraia where a guy was...it seemed like he was sweating blood from his back. Oh. And so with your body's inability to clot and prevent this internal bleeding, little bit by little bit, really becomes a serious problem pretty quick. So basically what this means is to make an antidote against snake venom,
比如牙龈、眼睛，有时是耳朵或是括约肌、肛门。哦天哪。如果情况真的很严重的话，澳大利亚曾发生过这样一件事：一个人的背部……看起来似乎在渗血。哦。由于你的身体无法凝固并阻止这种内出血，情况一点一点地迅速演变成一个严重的问题。所以，基本上这意味着要制造对抗蛇毒的解药，
we need to have something that can battle against that soup of toxins. And the thing is, you actually need different antivenoms for different snakes. So what saved Pete's life with the fertile land's anti-venom that wouldn't have worked if he'd gotten bit by, I don't know, a black mumble snake. And if you aren't Pete who can recognize fertile lands, you could be in real trouble then. I mean, you actually could and Pete took a photo of the snake. He knew it was a fertile land because he's beaten his GI Joe, but they took a photo and showed it to the doctors at the hospital. So what happens if you take the wrong antiventic
我们需要有能够对抗那盘毒素“乱炖”的东西。问题是，针对不同的蛇，你实际上需要不同的抗蛇毒血清。所以说，拯救皮特生命的是针对矛头蝮的抗蛇毒血清，如果他被别的什么咬了，比如说黑曼巴蛇，那就不起作用了。如果你不是皮特那样能认出矛头蝮的人，那你可就要倒大霉了。我是说，你真的会遇到麻烦，而且皮特拍下了那条蛇的照片。他知道那是矛头蝮，因为他就像特种部队一样懂行，他们拍了照片并拿给医院的医生看。那么，如果你用了错误的抗蛇毒血清会怎么样？
venom? It probably wouldn't work, like it wouldn't do anything. Bottom line, if they didn't have the fertile ants antiventic pep, then he probably would have died. Now to be clear, if you take the correct antiventic, it works and you know, this can save lives. So if you know the snake, and there's an antivenom for it, great. But you mentioned that making this antivenom is a complicated old process. What are you talking about there? Okay. Let me take you on a little journey of how we make antivenom today. It all starts with a kind of snake whisperer. Hello Wendy. So my name is Graving Corralis. Graving's worked with snakes for about a decade and he loves them,
它可能不会起作用，就像什么都不会发生一样。总而言之，如果他们没有针对矛头蝮的抗蛇毒血清，皮特可能就已经死了。需要明确的是，如果你用了正确的抗蛇毒血清，它就会起作用，你知道的，这能挽救生命。所以，如果你知道是什么蛇，并且有对应的抗蛇毒血清，那就太好了。但你提到制造这种抗蛇毒血清是一个复杂而古老的过程。你刚才是在说这个吗？好吧。让我带你们了解一下我们今天是如何制造抗蛇毒血清的。这一切都从一种“蛇语者”开始。你好，温迪。我叫格雷文·科拉利斯。格雷文跟蛇打交道大约有十年了，他非常喜欢蛇，
but these snakes don't always love him. Several years ago a Sri Lankan green pit viper bit his pinky finger. When you look at your finger now, what does it look like? So I actually lose a little part of my finger, it's like one centimeter or less than it used to be. Oh wow. I like it. It's really nice for a scrunchie. You kind of got to have this attitude if you do what Graven does. He works at a lab in Costa Rica called the Clotomiro Picato Institute, and they make the anti-venom that saved Pete's life. Inside Graven's workplace, there are rows of boxes filled with snakes. So we have about 500 snakes.
但这些蛇并不总是那么喜欢他。几年前，一条斯里兰卡竹叶青咬了他的小指。你现在看你的手指时，它长什么样？所以我的手指其实少了一截，大概只有一厘米或者比以前短了一点。哦哇。我很喜欢。绑发圈挺好用的。从事格雷文这份工作，你得有这种态度。他在哥斯达黎加一个名为克洛维米罗·皮卡多研究所的实验室工作，他们制造了拯救皮特生命的抗蛇毒血清。在格雷文的工作场所里，摆放着一排排装满蛇的箱子。所以我们大约有500条蛇。
What? Yeah, yeah. Okay, so to cook up anti-venom, first up, we need venom from a snake. So to make that stuff for pee, Graven had to go to a box with a fertile ants in it. We know, before we open the box, it's going to fight, because they are very explosive. They strike many times. Graven and his colleagues carefully take this riving angry snake out of the box, using wooden poles. Then they sedate the snake by popping it in a basket with carbon dioxide gas. When it goes under, when it's sedated, how long
什么？对，对。好吧，要配制抗蛇毒血清，首先，我们需要蛇的毒液。为了给皮特制作那东西，格雷文不得不走向一个装有矛头蝮的箱子。我们知道，在打开箱子之前，它就会发起攻击，因为它们的脾气非常暴躁。它们会发起多次攻击。格雷文和他的同事用木杆小心翼翼地把这条扭动着、发怒的蛇从箱子里弄出来。然后他们把蛇放进一个装有二氧化碳气体的篮子里将其麻醉。当它昏迷过去、被麻醉后，通常你还有
do you have before it wakes up generally? Around five minutes. Five minutes. So what's going through your mind as you're doing this? I know it sounds kind of crazy, but nothing like in this moment, I have to be very focused. You're holding not just a snake, but your partner's life. In that moment, you cannot feel no fear. You have to be fearless. And then Graven picks up the snake's head while his colleague holds the snake's body. And then Graven milks the snake. What is, what is milking the snake in tail?
多长时间它才会醒过来？大约五分钟。五分钟。所以你做这件事的时候，心里都在想些什么？我知道这听起来可能有点疯狂，但那一刻什么都没想，我必须非常专注。你手里握着的不只是一条蛇，还有你搭档的生命。在那一刻，你不能感到恐惧。你必须无所畏惧。然后，格雷文托起蛇的头部，而他的同事则按住蛇的身体。接着，格雷文开始对蛇进行“挤毒”。什么是——什么是挤毒？
I'm so glad you asked. Let me get this photo for you. Okay. Oh my goodness. Okay. They're holding the snake and there's a metal object prying the mouth open and the fangs are popped out and they're bringing the snake's head to a jar to collect the venom. Yes. So this is Graven in the picture and you can see that his index finger
很高兴你这么问。我来找一下这张照片给你看。好的。哦天哪。好吧。他们抓着蛇，有一个金属器具在撬开蛇的嘴，毒牙露了出来，他们把蛇的头凑向一个罐子来收集毒液。是的。照片里这个人就是格雷文，你可以看到他的食指
is kind of over the top of the snake's head. What he's going to be squishing down on is the venom gland of the snake, which is like this pouch, basically, that's filled with venom. So we have to do a little massage massage like a massage. Yeah. And I ask Grave to try and tell me what this feels like as someone who's never looked a snake. And he was like, he just couldn't tell me. He was like, it's like nothing you've ever felt before. And the closest thing he got was he was like, it's a bit like if you imagine a slice of
基本上按在蛇头上方。他要用力挤压的是蛇的毒腺，这个腺体基本上就像是一个装满毒液的囊。所以我们得做个小按摩，就像按摩一样。是的。我请格雷文试着向我描述一下这是一种什么感觉，作为一个从未挤过蛇毒的人。而他的反应是，他简直无法形容。他说，这感觉就像你从未体验过的任何东西。他能想到的最贴切的比喻是，他说，这有点像想象蛇皮下面夹着
an orange under snake skin. And you're kind of like squishing the orange. Okay. And then the juice comes out of the snake fangs. I see. I say, so it's a little tough. It's not like squishy. It had some resistance, but you push it on the back of the head and it pushes out a little bit of venom. Yes. Wow. Yeah. And Graven says that he can get around a teaspoon of venom from one fertile ant snake. Okay, so now he's massaged the venom out of this snake into a jar. What happens to the venom then? Okay, here's where it gets kind of ridiculous because now... Here's where? Okay. All right. I was waiting for it to get ridiculous. Because now, here's where? Okay.
一片橙子。然后你有点像在捏那个橙子。好吧。接着汁液就会从蛇牙里喷出来。我明白了。我是说，所以它有点硬。不是那种软绵绵的。它有一定的阻力，但你按压蛇的头部后面，它就会挤出一点毒液。是的。哇。是的。格雷文说，从一条矛头蝮蛇身上，他可以挤出大约一茶匙的毒液。好吧，现在他把毒液从蛇体内挤到罐子里了。接下来毒液会怎么样？好吧，接下来事情就变得有点荒谬了，因为现在……接下来去哪？好吧。好吧，我正等着它变得荒谬呢。因为现在，接下来去哪？好吧。
All right. I was waiting for it to get ridiculous. Well, because he is what we need a second group of animals. Oh, goodness. Okay. And we're going to call him the cavalry, because we literally need a file of horses. Whoa. Okay.
好吧，我正等着看它怎么荒谬呢。嗯，因为这里我们需要第二种动物。哦，天哪。好吧。我们打算叫它们“骑兵”，因为我们真的需要一个马厩的马匹。哇。好吧。
This is a turn. So, perhaps do you shake, but basically we need a large animal, for reasons that we'll become clear later. But at the center where Pete's anti-venom was made, there's about 120 horses. And there's also this guy, Jose Maria Gutiores. They're really fantastic animals. Do they have names? Yes, they have names.
这可真是个大转折。所以，也许你会觉得震惊，但基本上我们需要一种大型动物，原因稍后就会揭晓。但在制作皮特抗蛇毒血清的中心里，大约有120匹马。这里还有这个人，何塞·玛丽亚·古铁雷斯。它们是非常奇妙的动物。它们有名字吗？是的，它们有名字。
In fact, there was one horse one time with my name, so I was very proud of that. Jose Maria is a professor at the Clotter Mito Piccato Institute. Alright, so they're using all these horses because the anti-venom is actually going to be created inside the horse's body. And here's how. So, Chris and Maria's team will take that venom that Graven cooked out of the snake. And then you inject little
事实上，曾经有一匹马用过我的名字，所以我为此感到非常自豪。何塞·玛丽亚是克洛维米罗·皮卡多研究所的一位教授。好吧，所以他们用所有这些马是因为抗蛇毒血清实际上是在马的体内产生的。具体过程如下。何塞·玛丽亚的团队会拿走格雷文从蛇身上提取的毒液。然后将少量
amounts of venom into horses. And when when a horse is first injected with say a tiny amount of venom, how did they react to the they like, no, do you think it would be like like a mosquito bite? I think it would be a little more than that because we are injecting a toxic substance. So does this hurt the horse? Well, we don't know for sure, because the horse doesn't talk. Human speak.
毒液注射到马体内。当马第一次被注射微量的毒液时，它们会有什么反应？它们会觉得像蚊子叮咬一样吗？我想这可能不止于此，因为我们注射的是有毒物质。这会伤害马吗？嗯，我们无法确定，因为马不会说话。人类的语言。
But from what we can tell, there's a little bit of swelling around where they do the injection, nothing too serious though. And they're just injecting tiny, tiny amounts. And what's gonna happen next is that the horse is gonna be injected with venom every two weeks or so. And what they're doing is actually waiting for the horse's immune system to start building up
但据我们所观察到的，注射部位周围会有轻微的肿胀，不过没什么太严重的。而且他们注射的量非常非常小。接下来发生的事情是，每隔两周左右，马就会被注射一次毒液。他们这么做实际上是在等待马的免疫系统开始产生
antibodies against the venom. That's what we're here to harness. That is actually the anti-venom. Another way to think about it is that you're kind of vaccinating the horses against the venom. And then after several of these injections, usually a couple of months, for instance, at that point the horses are bled. They take around six liters of blood, which sounds like a lot, but Jose Maria says it's kind of the horse equivalent of donating a bag of blood at a blood bank.
针对毒液的抗体。这正是我们要利用的。这其实就是抗蛇毒血清。换一种方式来想，你这就相当于在给马注射对抗毒液的疫苗。在经过几次这样的注射（通常是几个月）后，这些马就会被放血。它们会被抽出大约六升血，听起来好像很多，但何塞·玛丽亚说，这相当于人类在血库里捐献一袋血的马类等效量。
Okay, that's not so bad. You get a cookie, you get some orange juice, you're all right. You get a bunch of day. And this is actually why we need horses because they're these big animals that can donate a lot of blood. So after all this, we get the very thing that we've been waiting for this miraculous drug that can fend off that super complicated cocktail of venom the horse antibodies They're purified then freeze dried and put into a vial and that is the stuff that gets injected into people like Pete So this antibodies this horse antibodies would get into the bloodstream they find the toxins and then they block the action of the toxins.
好吧，那倒也还好。你能得到一块曲奇饼干，能喝点橙汁，你就没事了。你会度过愉快的一天。这其实就是为什么我们需要马，因为它们是能够捐献大量血液的大型动物。经过这一切，我们得到了我们一直期盼的东西——这种神奇的药物，能够抵御那杯极其复杂的毒液鸡尾酒：马抗体。它们被纯化、冷冻干燥，然后装入小瓶中，这就是注射进像皮特这样的人体内东西。所以这些抗体，这些马抗体进入血液循环后，会找到毒素，然后阻断毒素的作用。
And so even though we say antibodies as if it's like one thing, within that vial of antivenom, there could be 50 different antibodies that go after 50 different toxins in the blood. Exactly. Actually, it's a mixture of antibodies and their antibodies against each of the toxins. And we need horses for this because they're these big animals and they can donate a lot of blood. And horses actually have a similar enough immune system to us, so their antibodies work
所以，尽管我们说“抗体”时好像它是一种单一的东西，但在那瓶抗蛇毒血清中，可能有50种不同的抗体，去对付血液中的50种不同毒素。没错。实际上，它是抗体的混合物，包含了针对每一种毒素的抗体。我们需要马是因为它们是大型动物，能够捐献大量血液。而且马的免疫系统和我们足够相似，所以它们的抗体对人类也起作用。
for humans. Chrysé Maria reckons that each bag of horse blood gets you enough antivenom to treat around 15 people. I mean, it's a super cool process and fascinating, but it also seems just way too complicated. Yeah, and then just to add a tiny bit more complexity here is to make antivenom for all the venomous steaks in the world. You actually need to inject horses with the specific venom from all those snakes in the world. And
何塞·玛丽亚估计，每袋马血提取出的抗蛇毒血清足够治疗大约15人。我的意思是，这是一个超级酷且迷人的过程，但它也显得实在太复杂了。是的，为了增加一点复杂度，要想为世界上所有有毒的蛇制造抗蛇毒血清，你实际上需要将世界上所有那些特定蛇类的毒液注射到马体内。
as all means we've got labs in Indonesia, in India, in Egypt, in South Africa, in Australia, that are just piled high with horses all getting injected with venom. And the thing is, we've basically made anti-venom the same way since the late 1800s. Wow, really nothing has changed in that time period. It's just the personnel and the horses, but it's the same process. Yeah, yeah, I mean, there have been some improvements, like in some cases, for example, the horses will go through this whole process, and instead of just being injected with one kind of venom, they'll be injected with three different kinds of venom.
这意味着我们在印度尼西亚、印度、埃及、南非和澳大利亚都拥有实验室，里面堆满了被注射了各种毒液的马。问题是，自19世纪末以来，我们基本上一直都是用同样的方式制造抗蛇毒血清。哇，这段时间里真的什么都没变吗？只有人员和马匹换了，但过程是一样的。是的，是的，我的意思是，也有一些改进，比如在某些情况下，马匹会经历整个过程，它们不再只被注射一种毒液，而是会被注射三种不同的毒液。
So that means they'll make all these antibodies for then three different kinds of venom. I see. So it's like a little bit more efficient, but the process is still basically the same. Yes, I think that's fair. Yes. So I guess the obvious question is,
这意味着它们会产生针对这三种不同毒液的所有抗体。我明白了。所以效率稍微提高了一点，但这个过程基本上还是老样子。是的，我觉得这样说很公平。是的。所以我想显而易见的问题是，
is we've been doing this for 100 plus years. Why are we still doing this way? Like why haven't we come up with a better way to do this? Yeah, it's a great question. And I think the dream for a lot of the people who work on this problem is to create a universal antivenom. So it's something that you could make in a lab and that could be used for heaps of different kinds of tanks for black numbers, for fertile answers, for rattlesnakes, and you wouldn't need to go through this whole process so many times in so many different countries. Well, it sounds super easy. Why don't we just do that? It's not easy and it takes a lot of time and innovative thinking and the big thing is money.
我们已经用这种方法一百多年了。为什么我们还在用这种方法？为什么我们没有想出一个更好的方法来做这件事呢？是的，这是一个很好的问题。我想，许多从事这个问题研究的人的梦想，就是创造一种通用的抗蛇毒血清。也就是说，你可以在实验室里制造出这种东西，它可以用于应对各种各样的蛇——黑曼巴蛇、矛头蝮、响尾蛇，而你不需要在那么多不同的国家重复这么多次整个繁琐的过程。听起来超级简单。我们为什么不直接那样做呢？这并不容易，需要大量的时间和创新思维，而最重要的问题是钱。
And for a long time, no one was really putting a lot of money into this space and that's for all kinds of complicated reasons. But if we had to boil it down to a word, I would say that word was capitalism. So as we talked about, snake bites kill around 100,000 people every year. This is a serious problem, but most of those deaths are happening in rural areas in Africa and Asia for people who can't afford a lot of money for medication. And drug companies haven't put a lot of funding into this to try and make things better, basically. But since 2017, things have started to change.
在很长一段时间里，没有人真正向这个领域投入大量资金，这其中有各种复杂的原因。但如果我们把它归结为一个词，我会说那个词就是资本主义。正如我们所讨论的，蛇咬伤每年夺去大约十万人的生命。这是一个严重的问题，但其中大多数死亡发生在非洲和亚洲的农村地区，那里的居民根本负担不起昂贵的药物。基本上，制药公司并没有在此投入大量资金来试图改善现状。但自2017年以来，情况开始发生变化。
What happened in 2017? Well, the World Health Organization gave snakefights this special designation. They listed them as the most important kind of neglected tropical disease. This sounds terribly nerdy and in the weeds, but basically what it means for a disease is that it's kind of like winning in the oscar. You get extra attention, you get extra money. That is basically what's happened.
2017年发生了什么？嗯，世界卫生组织给蛇咬伤给予了一个特殊的称号。他们将其列为最重要的被忽视的热带病之一。这听起来可能极其小众且深奥，但对于一种疾病来说，这基本上就像是在奥斯卡上获奖。你会获得额外的关注，获得更多的资金。这基本上就是所发生的事情。
We've seen this real change in what's going on. You see more research in this space. And after more than a hundred years of making antivenom with the horses and the snakes, now there's all these new ideas on the horizon. And Jose Maria says that this has all been huge. Things have really changed. The world in general is paying much more attention
我们看到了现状的真正转变。你会看到这个领域有更多的研究。在用马和蛇制造了100多年抗蛇毒血清之后，现在地平线上涌现出了所有这些新想法。何塞·玛丽亚说，这一切都是巨大的突破。情况真的变了。全世界普遍对这种疾病给予了更多的关注
to this disease. And it's really exciting. And it's really exciting. So now that snake bites have gotten the amount of attention they deserve, where are we with the universal antivetham? We're starting to see some really exciting things in the science. So one of them is that at the same time as snake bites have gotten all this extra attention, scientists also developed these better tools to be able to look inside venom and analyze those toxins. And what we're realizing is that even though there are thousands of toxins doing slightly different things,
，这真的很让人兴奋。这真的很让人兴奋。既然蛇咬伤已经得到了它们应有的关注，我们在通用抗蛇毒血清的研究上进展到哪一步了？我们在科学研究中开始看到一些非常令人兴奋的进展。其中之一就是，在蛇咬伤获得所有这些额外关注的同时，科学家们还开发出了更好的工具，能够深入蛇毒内部并分析这些毒素。我们意识到，尽管有数千种发挥着略微不同作用的毒素，
you can actually group them together into families of toxins and then try and tackle those families and it's a much easier target. You can think about it like this. Are you a basketball fan? Not especially, but we'll continue on. Excellent. A huge basketball fan in the corner here. All right, so this is kind of how I've been thinking about the way that they're tackling this universal anti-bed and problem. If you say you're in the NBA and you've got to play again, All right, so this is kind of how I've been thinking about the way that they're tackling this universal anti-bed and problem. If say you're in the NBA and you've got to play against hundreds of players in the league, one way to do that would be to try and figure out the defense
但你实际上可以把它们归类为不同的毒素家族，然后尝试针对这些家族进行攻克，这样目标就容易得多了。你可以这样想。你是篮球迷吗？算不上特别喜欢，但我们可以继续。太好了。角落里正坐着一个超级篮球迷。好吧，这就是我一直在思考他们攻克这种通用抗蛇毒血清难题的方式。如果你在NBA打球，你得面对比赛，好吧，这就是我一直在思考他们攻克这种通用抗蛇毒血清难题的方式。如果你在NBA打球，你得和联盟里的数百名球员同场竞技，应对的方法之一就是去摸清
of all the individual players. You know, you carry LeBron and even all the middle-level players and all the ones on the bench, like even Bobon, you've got to work out what's going on with him. Well, of course, I mean, I think about Bobon all the time. But I guess contextually, I'm to assume that Bobon is not exactly a LeBron or a Curry. No, but he's doing his best. Okay, great. Exactly. So you've got to work out each player's individual tricks. Instead, what we're doing now is we're just looking at what the big, dangerous players
所有单兵球员的防守。你知道，你得防勒布朗，甚至还要应付所有中游水平的球员以及板凳席上的所有人，甚至连博班，你都得搞清楚他到底是怎样的。当然了，我的意思是，我无时无刻不在想博班。但我想在语境上，我应该假设博班并不完全是勒布朗或库里那样的球星。不，但他已经在尽力了。好吧，太好了。没错。所以你必须摸清每个球员各自的绝招。相反，我们现在做的是，我们只看那些大牌、危险的球员
are doing and grouping them together and then working out a defense against them. So just focusing on Steph Curry and all the Curry copycats out there. Okay, that makes sense. So if you know that the toxin hits a lot of three pointers, you're basically like making a medicine to deal with that particular attack. It's the anti-three pointer medicine. Exactly. Exactly.
在干什么，然后把他们归为一类，并针对他们研究出一套防守策略。也就是只专注于斯蒂芬·库里以及所有那些库里的模仿者们。好吧，这说得通。所以如果你知道某种毒素经常投三分球，你基本上就是针对那种特定的攻击来制造药物。这就是“抗三分球药物”。没错。没错。
And so has this approach been working so far? You know, it's been going well. So for example, there's this big family of enzymes that are swimming inside venom and what they do is damage blood vessels. And they're called metallic protonazers. And they're found in viper's all around the world. And so scientists have now been searching for a way to basically stop metallic protonazers
那么，这种方法目前管用吗？你知道的，进展很顺利。举个例子，有一种庞大的酶家族在毒液里游走，它们的作用是破坏血管。它们被称为金属蛋白酶。全世界的毒蛇体内都有这种酶。因此，科学家们现在一直在寻找一种方法来阻止金属蛋白酶
from working. This is one of those scientists. Go on, introduce yourself. Yeah, so I'm Laura Alblastcu. I work at the Liverpool School of Tropical Medicine. And scientists like Laura are trying to figure out how to protect us against that big family of nasty enzymes. And to do that, she's been thinking, well, what do the enzymes need to survive?
发挥作用。这位就是其中一位科学家。来吧，自我介绍一下。好的，我是劳拉·阿尔布拉斯库。我在利物浦热带医学院工作。像劳拉这样的科学家正试图找出如何保护我们免受那个庞大的有害酶家族的侵害。为了做到这一点，她一直在思考：这些酶生存需要什么？
And they've discovered that one of the things these enzymes need is zinc. And Laura says there's actually already a drug on the market that messes with zinc. So Laura and her team took this drug and then combined it with another drug. And then they enlisted some heroic little white mice and injected them with some snake venom from some of the most dangerous snakes in the world. We are looking at vipers from Africa, from India, from Central America. They waited a bit to let the venom set in, then gave them the concoction, the two drugs. Now, if this didn't work, most likely. These mice would all die within a four-hour window.
他们发现这些酶生存所需的其中一样东西就是锌。劳拉说，市面上其实已经有一种能干扰锌的药物了。于是，劳拉和她的团队拿了这种药物，并将其与另一种药物结合起来。接着，他们招募了一些英勇的小白鼠，并给它们注射了来自世界上几种最危险毒蛇的蛇毒。我们观察的毒蛇来自非洲、印度和中美洲。他们等了一会儿让毒素发作，然后给小白鼠服用了这种由两种药物组成的混合剂。如果这不管用，最有可能的结果是，
But instead, the team saw something different. The mice started moving around, sniffing, they seemed to be recovering. These animals are still alive and look healthy. And how are you feeling? Yeah, I was feeling great. I didn't expect it to work so well against animals that are so different from each other. Yeah, to work for a fertile ants from Central America
这些小白鼠都会在四个小时内全部死亡。但相反，团队看到了不同的景象。小白鼠开始走动、嗅闻，它们似乎在恢复。这些动物还活着，看起来很健康。你现在感觉怎么样？是的，我感觉棒极了。我没想到它对这些生理差异如此巨大的动物能这么有效。没错，对中美洲的矛头蝮
and then an Asian, you had sore scaled viper. Yeah, to work for a fertile ants from Central America and then an Asian, you had sore scaled viper. Yeah. How big is that in the world of Antivenom? This is amazing. It's really great. It's really important. So they have it after a hundred years of needing to inject horses with all these different kinds of venom. Laura's drug has worked. We did it, Roman! I'm a feeling that we did not do it. That's not how science works.
以及亚洲的锯鳞毒蛇都有效。对中美洲的矛头蝮以及亚洲的锯鳞毒蛇都有效。这在抗蛇毒血清领域有多大意义？这太惊人了。真的太棒了。这非常重要。所以你看，在经历了一百年需要向马匹注射各种不同毒液的历史后，劳拉的药成功了。我们成功了，罗曼！我有种预感，我们其实并没有成功。科学可不是这么运作的。
One clinical test doesn't do it. No. And actually one of the mice did die 18 hours later. But, but, but, but, this tactic is actually showing so much promise that there's already a clinical trial in humans underway that's focusing on another drug that messes with zinc. That's great, and this is a completely different approach. I mean, using drugs rather than using antibodies from another animal is like, it's completely novel.
一次临床测试可说明不了问题。没有。事实上，其中一只小白鼠在18小时后还是死了。但是，但是，但是，这种策略实际上展现出了巨大的前景，针对另一种干扰锌的药物的人类临床试验已经在进行中了。太棒了，这是一种完全不同的方法。我的意思是，使用药物而不是使用来自另一种动物的抗体，完全是开创性的。
No, exactly. I mean, it's novel in the world of snake bites, but it's what we do for basically every other disease out there. And you know, the antivenom that we have now, it does work when you can get it. And so scientists are thinking that maybe in the shortage term, we might have these new and exciting treatments that kind of work alongside the antivenom from the horses. It's funny because like,
不，完全没错。我是说，这在蛇咬伤领域是开创性的，但这正是我们对待其他几乎所有疾病的方式。你知道，我们现在拥有的抗蛇毒血清，在你弄到手的时候确实管用。所以科学家们认为，也许在短期内，我们会拥有这些全新且令人兴奋的疗法，它们可以与来自马匹的抗蛇毒血清协同发挥作用。这挺有意思的，因为
you know, we've spent a year with COVID-19 and we saw a series of vaccines go from design to trial to approval in under a year. And that's not how science normally works ever. Usually it's a process where you try things, lots of mice die, and after years of experiments, I mean, maybe we have a small breakthrough. Yeah, I mean, I think the COVID-19 story, it could tell us two things and Tom will tell. Like, perhaps this virus was actually surprisingly easy to make a vaccine for.
你知道的，我们经历了一整年的COVID-19疫情，我们看到一系列疫苗从设计、试验到批准在不到一年的时间里就完成了。这可不是科学通常的运作方式。通常这是一个需要不断尝试的过程，无数小白鼠死去，经过多年的实验，我的意思是，也许我们才会有微小的突破。是的，我的意思是，COVID-19的故事可以告诉我们两件事，时间会证明一切。比如，也许这种病毒制造疫苗实际上出奇地容易。
And we were kind of lucky and a nasty a virus could have come around that we couldn't have had a vaccine for. But maybe the other lesson here is that if scientists get bucket loads of money and basically you encourage nerds from all around the world to tackle a problem, that they could solve it very quickly. Yeah, yeah. It's like a Manhattan Project or, you know, sending a person to the moon, you know, it's just like, if you put enough money and will behind it, you can make it happen.
我们算是有点走运，本来可能会出现一种让我们无法研发出疫苗的超级恶劣病毒。但这里的另一个教训可能是，如果科学家们获得大量的资金，并且基本上鼓励全世界的书呆子们去攻克一个难题，他们就能非常迅速地解决它。对，对。就像曼哈顿计划，或者把人送上月球那样，你知道的，这就好比，如果你投入足够的资金和意志力，你就能让它变成现实。
Exactly. Exactly. And so maybe that will happen with snake anti-vendom too, if enough scientists and there's enough excitement around this area. Okay, so I've one more question before we go. Like, what happened to Pete? You know, he got bit by this snake. He nearly died. Is he still traipsing around as this conservationist, Gio Joe. Yes, there's no change in Pete Watts, however. He is still in Costa Rica. He's going to be patrolling the jogger's suit. And he said his leg is doing all right. In the meantime, he actually still
完全正确。完全正确。所以如果投入足够的科学家，并且这个领域有足够的兴奋点，也许蛇用抗蛇毒血清也会迎来这样的突破。好吧，在我离开前我还有一个问题。皮特后来怎么样了？你知道的，他被这条蛇咬了。他差点死了。他现在还在像特种部队那样到处游荡当环保主义者吗？是的，皮特的本性一点没变。他还在哥斯达黎加。他将继续在慢跑者的雨林里巡逻。他说他的腿感觉还不错。与此同时，他其实在内心深处
holds a little place in his heart for the snake that got him. I'm happy that Guy is still alive and up there. So you don't hold the grudge against the snakey? No, I'm happy that Gaur is still alive and up there. So you don't hold the grudge against the snakey? No, I don't hold a grudge against the snake. He was just doing snake things. He does a good attitude. Thank you Wendy. Thanks Robert. More strange fascinating snake content with Wendy's Sookerman. After this. So I'm back with Wendy's Sookerman from Science versus Wendy.
对那条咬他的蛇还保留着一丝喜爱。我很高兴那家伙还活着，还在那儿。所以你对那条蛇没有什么怨恨吗？不，我很高兴那家伙还活着，还在那儿。所以你对那条蛇没有什么怨恨吗？不，我对那条蛇没有任何怨恨。它只是在做蛇该做的事。他的心态真好。谢谢你，温迪。谢谢罗曼。接下来还有更多关于温迪·祖克曼带来的奇妙有趣的蛇类内容。休息一下马上回来。欢迎回来，我是《科学对决》的温迪·祖克曼。
Let us talk more about snakes. Yes, please. So as I've been researching this episode, I realized there were all these things about snakes that I had never thought about before. Like they're quite beautiful. They have all these different colors on their scales. And I also realized how little science knows about some, what I would have thought were pretty basic snake things. I also realized how little science knows about some,
让我们来聊聊更多关于蛇的话题。好的，请吧。在研究这一集的过程中，我意识到关于蛇有许多我以前从未想过的事情。比如它们其实非常美丽。它们的鳞片上有各种各样的颜色。我也意识到，科学界对某些我原本以为是很基础的蛇类常识知之甚少。我也意识到，科学界对某些，
what I would have thought were pretty basic snake things. Like, for example. Like, scientists still aren't sure if snakes can hear. Like hear it all? Yeah, yeah. So, Dr. Christine Isidanec, who we heard from in the first half of the show, she's like, you know, we know snakes can feel vibrations.
我原本以为是很基础的蛇类常识知之甚少。比如。比如，科学家至今仍不确定蛇是否能听见声音。是完全能听见吗？对，对。所以我们在节目前半部分听过的主讲人克里斯蒂娜·伊齐达内克就说过，你知道的，我们知道蛇能感受到震动。
That's what we're taught. I don't know if. I actually don't know if you're taught this in them. But every Australian knows that if you exceed a snake, you've got to stamp your feet to try and get them to feel. Okay, so we know snakes can feel vibrations, but we didn't know whether they could hear sounds through the air. And a big reason for that is that they don't have external ears. Which ever since she told me that I just can't stop imagining it with external ears. I mean, that is the only way we'd really know is if they had big old ears. You're right. I'm not on their side of their hands. And so, so because they don't have this, you know, for a long time subscibe, just like, well, we just don't think they can hear. And then Christina heard this kind of a basic story
这就是我们所受的教育。我不知道。我其实不知道你是不是受过这种教育。但每个澳大利亚人都知道，如果你看到一条蛇，你得跺脚，试着让它们感受到震动。好吧，所以我们知道蛇能感受到震动，但我们不知道它们是否能通过空气听到声音。而这其中的一个主要原因在于，它们没有外耳。自从她告诉我这件事后，我就忍不住想象它们长着外耳的样子。我的意思是，我们真正能知道的唯一方法就是它们长着大大的外耳。你说得对。长在它们脑袋的两侧。所以，因为它们没有这个，很长一段时间里科学家们都觉得，好吧，我们就是觉得它们听不见。然后克里斯蒂娜听到了一个关于这方面挺基础的故事
for one of her colleagues, Damien Kendu. So, and I want to tell you, it's, I mean, in some ways, it's like, I can't, I can't imagine a more stereotypical Australian story. So I am nervous to bring this to more Americans, but you're in a safe space here. Thank you. Thank you. So this guy, he sometimes makes the sound effects to more Americans, but... That you're in a safe space here. Thank you. Thank you.
来自她的同事达米安·肯杜。所以，我想告诉你的是，从某种程度上讲，这简直是——我简直无法想象还有比这更具刻板印象的澳大利亚故事了。所以我向更多美国人讲这个时还有点紧张，但你现在身处一个安全的空间。谢谢。谢谢。所以这家伙，他有时会为电影制作音效——向更多美国人讲这个时……你现在身处一个安全的空间。谢谢。谢谢。
So this guy, he sometimes makes the sound effects for films and he noticed that while he was working on what he called low-end frequencies, so think like bombs exploding, you know, that like, pooh, and like earthquakes where you hear those tremors in a cinema. Yeah. And so while he was creating those sounds, he would notice that brown snakes would start slithering next to his house.
所以这家伙，他有时会为电影制作音效，他注意到当他在处理他所谓的低频声音时（想想看，比如炸弹爆炸的声音，你知道的，那种“轰”的声音，还有电影院里能听到那种震颤的地震音效）。是的。所以当他创作这些声音时，他会注意到棕伊蛇开始在他的房子旁边蜿蜒爬行。
From seemingly nowhere. He didn't know why it could have been a coincidence. It could have been that they were feeling vibrations or maybe because they really could hear the sound waves through the air. And so he ends up telling the story to Christina. And Christina was like, yeah, you know, there are a few studies suggesting like maybe snakes can hear, you know, still this huge debate. And so just this year, they teamed up and decided to test it.
似乎凭空出现。他不知道为什么，这可能只是个巧合。可能是因为它们感受到了震动，或者也许是因为它们真的能通过空气听到声波。于是他把这个故事讲给了克里斯蒂娜听。克里斯蒂娜听后觉得，是的，你知道的，有少数研究表明蛇可能听得到声音，你知道这仍然是一个巨大的争论点。所以就在今年，他们联手决定对此进行测试。
We've got a soundproof room and we've got 19 catch of snakes. What her team does is they take the snake out of its holding container, which is essentially like a rubbish bin with some holes in the lid. Grabbing the snake with a hook and then with his hand when it's safe. And then they put the snake into this soundproof room. We've got a half-ball, which we've just secured the door for, for security. Christina sent me a photo. It's literally fancier than the Gimlett studios. And definitely more secure. And then they give this snake some time to settle. So then they play some sounds
我们有一个隔音室，还有19条抓来的蛇。她的团队所做的就是把蛇从它们的容器里拿出来，这个容器本质上就像是一个盖子上带孔的垃圾桶。先用钩子抓住蛇，在安全的时候再用手抓。然后他们把蛇放进这个隔音室。我们有一个半球形装置，为了安全起见，我们刚刚把门锁上了。克里斯蒂娜给我发了一张照片。这简直比吉姆利特工作室的还要高档。而且绝对更安全。然后他们给这条蛇一些时间适应。接着他们播放一些声音
through this very special setup they have that's basically designed so that the sounds come through the air and they don't make vibrations on the floor. I see, right. And then she's basically recording the snake's behavior. Just started the sound. She dropped her lower jaw, which is quite interesting, a defensive pose. And now she's flicking her tongue and slightly moving around, head raised off the ground, peering into the distance, still
通过他们设置的这个非常特殊的装置，基本上设计成让声音通过空气传播，而不会在地板上产生振动。我明白了，对。然后她基本上是在记录蛇的行为。刚刚开始播放声音。她下颌下垂，这很有趣，是一种防御姿态。现在她正在吐舌头，身体稍微移动，头部抬离地面，向远处张望，依然
flicking the tongue, not making any large movements. So what did they find? Do snakes actually hear the sound? Okay, she's still analyzing the data, but he is what she told me about it. There's some very interesting behaviors. I think it will be clear at least with some of the individuals that they're absolutely going to be aware of the sound. What I think is pretty cool with what Christina is starting to see is that
在吐舌头，没有做太大的动作。那么他们发现了什么？蛇真的能听到声音吗？好吧，她仍在分析数据，但这是她告诉我的情况。有一些非常有趣的行为。我认为至少对于某些个体来说，可以肯定的是它们绝对会察觉到这个声音。我认为克里斯蒂娜开始看到的一个非常酷的现象是，
the behavior she's seeing is really dependent on the individual snake, right? And so here's what she said about that. How they respond, I think, it seems to be based on the individual personality, whether they're a type of a timid snake or whether they're sort of more defensive and willing to give more defensive behaviors and by that and a snake would be dropping their lower jaw to show their fangs or hissing. Do you think about snakes as having personalities? Yes, we see it all the time.
她看到的行为实际上取决于个体蛇，对吧？她对此是这样说的：它们的反应，我认为，似乎取决于它们的个性，它们是那种胆小的蛇，还是那种更具防御性、更愿意表现出防御行为的蛇。所谓的防御行为就是蛇会下垂下颌来展示毒牙或发出嘶嘶声。你觉得蛇也有个性吗？是的，我们经常看到。
So my husband and I, we have 24 snakes as pets. And so we see it on a very intimate level. One snake doesn't like to be touched, another one could care less. One basically like falls asleep in your hands. He's like, this old man. He's literally 21 years old. He's like, you know, 2.2 meter coast of Taipei, like they're very sort of predictable in their personalities. And so to take this back to the experiment, so in the tape where we were hearing about the experiment, Christina's describing the snake, the tissing,
我和我丈夫养了24条宠物蛇。所以我们在一个非常亲密的层面观察到了这一点。一条蛇不喜欢被摸，另一条则完全不在乎。还有一条基本上会在你手里睡着。他就像个老头子。他 literalmente（字面意思）21岁了。他就像是那种2.2米长的沿海太攀蛇，它们的个性非常容易预测。回到实验上来，在录音中我们听到了关于实验的描述，克里斯蒂娜在描述那条蛇的嘶嘶声，
and getting all pissy at the sound, that's a coastal type-an. But it's not this sleepy guy that she's talking about, she is. That sleepy guy was also in the experiment, and she said that he basically fell asleep when he heard the sounds. So this is perfect example of how she's seen these different reactions. By the way, just to get a sense of how big that sleepy snake is, she said 2.2 meters.
并且对声音感到非常恼火，那是一条沿海太攀蛇。但她谈论的可不是这个爱睡觉的家伙，她说的就是那个爱睡觉的家伙也参与了实验，她说当听到声音时，那家伙基本上直接睡着了。所以这是一个完美的例子，说明她是如何看到这些截然不同的反应的。顺便说一句，为了让你感受一下那条爱睡觉的蛇有多大，她说有2.2米长。
It's about the same height as Bobon, the basketball player. It all comes back to Bobon. That's fantastic. Right, did you ever think of snakes as having personalities? I mean, I had a snake, and I didn't have a lot of exposure. That one seemed to have a personality. It was named Tupac. I was corn snake, but like I didn't have a lot of other snakes to compare it to. So it had personality, but I didn't realize how, you know, maybe different. It was from other corn snakes. But, you know, Chui was a great snake
这大约和篮球运动员博班一样高。一切又回到了博班。太棒了。对啊，你以前想过蛇也有个性吗？我是说，我曾经养过一条蛇，而且我没有接触过很多蛇。那条蛇似乎确实有性格。它叫图派克。我养的是一条玉米蛇，但我没有很多其他的蛇来跟它作比较。所以它有性格，但我没有意识到它和其他玉米蛇相比，你知道，可能有多么不同。不过，你知道，奇伊是一条很棒的蛇，
and would escape on occasion and then show up four days later, like right next to the cage. Oh wow, like a cat, like cats do that. Exactly, yeah. So it doesn't surprise me that they have some personality, the fact that one would get really exercised upon watching a Chris
偶尔会逃跑，然后四天后又出现，就像在笼子旁边一样。哦，天哪，就像猫一样，猫就会做这种事。完全是这样。所以这并不让我感到意外，它们确实有一些性格，事实上，一条蛇在看克里斯托弗·诺兰的电影时会变得非常激动，
for Nolan movie, another one would be completely nonplussed by it. It isn't like, it's new to me though. That's fantastic. And you to science, I think. I like it. Thank you. Thanks.
而另一条则完全无动于衷。不过这对我来说还是挺新鲜的。太棒了。对科学界来说也是如此，我想。我喜欢。谢谢。谢谢。
A version of this episode can be heard on the wonderful podcast Science vs. a production of Gimlett, a Spotify company. I'm a huge science vs. fan. I've been a fan since the very first episode that I heard when they were just a little Australian show. And now they're this big global phenomenon. I'm so excited we had this chance to work with them. Special thanks this week to Wendy Zookerman and the whole team at Science Versus,
本集的精简版可以在精彩的播客“Science Vs”中收听，该播客由 Spotify 旗下的 Gimlett 制作。我是“Science Vs”的超级粉丝。自从听到他们还是个小型澳大利亚节目时的第一集起，我就一直是他们的粉丝。现在他们已经成为了一个巨大的全球现象。我很高兴我们能有机会与他们合作。本周要特别感谢温迪·祖克曼（Wendy Zookerman）以及“Science Vs”团队的所有成员，
including Blithe Terrell, Rose from Lur, Merrill Horn, Nick Del Rose, Michelle Dang, and Taylor White. Also special thanks to Maxwell Simian, a gimlet. 99% invisible was produced this week by Chris Baroube, music by our director of Sound Sean Riel, sound mix by Bryson Barnes,, music by our director of Sound Sean Riel, sound mix by Bryson Barnes, fact checking by Erica Akiko Howard. Our senior producer is Delaney Hall, Kurt Colestead is the digital director, Thrasadin,
包括布莱思·特雷尔（Blithe Terrell）、罗斯·弗罗姆·勒（Rose from Lur）、梅里尔·霍恩（Merrill Horn）、尼克·德尔·罗斯（Nick Del Rose）、米歇尔·当（Michelle Dang）和泰勒·怀特（Taylor White）。还要特别感谢 Gimlett 的麦克斯韦·西米安（Maxwell Simian）。本周的《99%无形》由克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Baroube）制作，我们的声音总监肖恩·里尔（Sean Riel）负责音乐，声音混音由布赖森·巴恩斯（Bryson Barnes）完成，音乐由我们的声音总监肖恩·里尔（Sean Riel）负责，声音混音由布赖森·巴恩斯（Bryson Barnes）完成，事实核查由埃里卡·阿基科·霍华德（Erica Akiko Howard）完成。我们的高级制作人是德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall），库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colestead）是数字总监，
includes Emmett Fitzgerald, Joe Rosenberg, Vivian Le, Christopher Johnson, Abby Medon, Katie Mingle, Sophia Glasgow, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW and San Francisco improduced on Radio Ro, which is scattered across the continent right now, but will always be centered in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. We're a founding member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative listener supported 100% artist own podcasts in the world. Find them all at radiotopia.fm.
成员包括埃梅特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、薇薇安·勒（Vivian Le）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、艾比·梅登（Abby Medon）、凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）、索菲亚·格拉斯哥（Sophia Glasgow）以及我罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。我们是 91.7 KALW 和旧金山 Radio Ro 的合作项目，电台目前分布在大陆各地，但将永远以美丽、繁华的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心为核心。我们是 PRX 旗下 Radiotopia 的创始成员，这是一个由世界上最具创新性、由听众支持的、100%艺术家所有的独立播客组成的激烈独立的集体。请访问 radiotopia.fm 了解详情。
You can tweet me at Ron Mars on the show at 9-9-PI-org or on Instagram and read it too. And you can find our home on the internet at 9-9-PI-dot-org. Radio Tapio. From PRX. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在推特上@Ron Mars，或者通过节目邮箱 9-9-PI-org 与我们联系，也可以在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上找到我们。你可以在互联网上的 9-9-PI-dot-org 找到我们的主页。来自 PRX 的 Radiotopia。目前这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。